bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france elle ces morts
supplémentaires qui ne sont donc pas
intégrés aux chiffres alliés aux copies
est ce que ce sont des cas d'
coronavirus mal recensé ou bien des
conséquences de la crise liée au fait
notamment que les gens se sont peut-être
moins soigné depuis le début de la crise
non il faut distinguer dans la
surmortalité qu'elle en a observé deux
choses d'une part une surmortalité due à
la maladie
et cette surmortalité due à la maladie
elle est surtout frappante dans les pays
qui ont confiné comme à la france est
terre de meilleur policière en enfermant
indistinctement les gens malades et les
gens sains permettant ainsi de
contaminer les gens sains et donc
d'étendre les pirelli
ces quatre pays européens que vous avez
cités l'italie l'espagne la france et la
belgique puisque la belgique atteint le
record européen de mortalité par million
d'habitants
ces quatre pays sont les adeptes du
confinement policier brutal à la
française
à l'opposé les pays qui ont adopté des
attitudes tout à fait traditionnelle de
séparation des malades des autres ont
des taux qui se rapproche des taux
asiatique des pays libéraux tôt comme
taïwan le japon et la corée du sud qui
vont des mortalités de l'ordre de 1 à 5
par million d'habitants alors qu'en
france nous sommes à 440 et en belgique
à plus de 700 donc vous voyez la marche
colossal et donc danser mort du co vides
il y a directement les morts uniquement
de l'enfermement à la française et cela
explique herman visible lorsqu'on
regarde les bis qui ont à peu près rien
fait en europe il ya trois pays qui
n'ont pas confiné du tout et qui ou
simplement fermer les lieux de rendez
vous les plus serrées eh bien ces pays
sont les pays bas la suède et
l'islande et ces trois pays ont des
chiffres nettement inférieurs pour noël
par exemple pour les pays bas c'est 30 %
moins deux morts deux co vide que la
france donc non seulement le confinement
à la française n'a pas été efficace mais
il a été directement je deviens
directement délétère sur les morts
directement dus à la maladie
mais à côté de cette surmortalité due à
la maladie et surtout au confinement
qu'on nous a imposée il y a les
mentalités directement dus au
confinement en dehors de la malvie les
lois importantes et qui sont dues aux
mesures qui ont été prises
or un exemple c'est les gens qui
devaient traitées pour un cancer qui
devait être père et qui disent avoir une
chimiothérapie
le plan blanc imposer à la france a
interdit ou chirurgien d'opérer ou doit
offrir uniquement les urgences reconnu
par les agences régionales de santé
tous les autres eh ben ils attendent
autrement dit les chirurgies prévu les
consultations et les adaptations de
traitement fait pour les hypertensions
artérielles pour le dépistage des
possibles anévrismes cérébraux pour
toutes sortes de maladies
toutes les maladies chroniques ont été
abandonnées alors bien sûr
depuis quelques temps on a des messages
du gouvernement qui nous disent
consulter à nouveau c'est dangereux et
ça oui mais la peur a été tellement
instiller dans la population
vous continuez d'ailleurs vous et rt
ambre en disant il ya ces locaux vides
est encore là puisque c'est kawasaki
c'est quand même une stupidité de même
si c'est l'om est ce qu'il le dit si
stupide kawasaki est connu depuis plus
de 50 ans locaux ville ils datent de
trois mois ou six mois
alors comment peut-on prétendre que le
kawasaki une conséquence du co lead on
peut dire qu'il ya une association
éventuel tu mérites d discuté langue en
compte ce n'est pas une conséquence quoi
qu'on puisse raconter
donc c'est vraiment essayé d'instiller
la peur de plus on on prétend que la
maladie
va poursuivre or tous les chiffres
officiels de l oms montrent qu'en europe
la maladie et sur la fin la chute par
exemple dans les cinq dernières semaines
en france de nouveaux cas de maladie la
chute est de 80% alors comment peut-on
prétendre que la mairie va se poursuivre
il faut enfin se dire que la maladie est
terminée qui est on doit arrêter tous
les confinements on doit cesser avec ce
cinéma d'empêcher des gens d'aller sur
les plages et de gêner les enfants dans
les écoles avec toutes ces mesures de
séparation idiote dont personne n'a
jamais démontré qu'elles servent à
quelque chose et on peut leur demander
aux français de revivre normalement sans
peur alors il ne s'agit pas tant à
monsieur d'instiller la peur on se
réfère au cir ces études menées par des
scientifiques
si on vous entend finalement il n'aurait
pas fallu confiné et autre question
comment est ce que vous voyez les
prochaines semaines en terme médical
notamment après ce confinement en
quelques mots alors non il fallait pas
confiné c'est tout à fait évident quand
on regarde les résultats officiels
devraient publier
bien entendu vous avez plein d'études
actuellement qui sont de commandes à mon
avis et qui prétendent qu'on aille
dernier cinquante mille vies en france
exhorte tout ça repose sur des
simulations dire on a créé les moeurs
virtuel par ordinateur et nous dit
voyons madame beaucoup moins de morts
que les mort virtuelle de l'ordinateur
c'est ça le modèle non regardons les
faits avérés les faits établis alors
comment est ce que je vois pour les
semaine prochaine si on arrête de faire
ce cinéma effroyable d' empêcher les
gens d'aller se promener sur les plages
les toutes sortes de choses et les
enfants si on arrête de faire peur aux
enfants parce que voilà pour les enfants
séparés de leur copain avec des
barrières de deux mètres etc
c'est leur faire croire qu'il ya un
danger évident donc ce n'est pas
raisonnable
il faut arrêter de que d'avoir tous ces
indices de peur à la population
et effectivement il y a la peur à une
époque en france
le str annie par exemple on merci on
aura sans doute l'occasion de reprendre
ce sujet et on comprend évidemment que
les théories les avis divergent d'un
conte d'un scientifique à l'autre
mercier et gérard delépine je rappelle
que vous êtes un chirurgien esthétique
les chiens il y fait